he's an American rapper record producer
and entrepreneur he is a very successful
hip-hop artist he's worth 550 million
dollars he's jay-z and he are his top 10
rules for success my advice is just do
things that are true to you
you know you know most things that I'm
involved with our extension of being
creative you know Rockaway is a clothing
company you know it's part of who you
are and hip-hop is your attitude and
what you're trying to express express
how you dress comes you know I love
sports growing up I grew up in a
household where sports was on 24/7 so
these are things that are you know are
comfortable for me you know these are
things that I like so I would just say
get involved in things that you love and
also have you know have a standard for
yourself and have some sort of integrity
and try to you know find some sort of
truth in what you're doing I think again
again it goes back to a bit of a warm
saying as well like it's the discipline
as well the discipline to not get caught
up in the moment you know music is like
stocks too you know there's the hot
thing of the moment you know there's
this hot electro sound or the hot
auto-tuned voice or the hot
whatever whatever it's new and exciting
and you know you know people tend to
make emotional decisions based on that
you don't stick with what they know this
is who I am this is what you know this
is what I do and then they you know jump
on this next hot thing and you know it's
not for you so for me just having a
discipline and having the confidence
that it and who I am you know and if I
go into a studio and if I find my truth
of the moment they're there there are a
number of people in the world that can
relate to what I'm saying and and it's
gonna buy into what I'm doing you know
not because it's the new thing at the
moment but because it's my genuine
emotions is how I feel this out I
articulate the world and you know just
having to discipline to just you know
yourself yeah I'm inspired by you know
life and all sorts of things you can say
something right now and would inspire me
to write a song or something to happen
you know most kids just happen to be
inspired by Basquiat drawing you know
the drawing and yet most young kings get
the head cut off on the bottom and I
looked at that and I was like it's
powerful
you know this the statement in itself
you know lends itself for a song song
starts inspired by Basquiat my chariots
on fire everybody took shots at my body
up I'm tired in the nesters they build
me up to break me down to build me up
again they like hope we need you back so
we could kill yes again you know it's
like this thing that's love/hate thing
that the world has with success period
it's it's complex right and it's
deceiving mmm at times you know there's
people think the to equate yes you know
to each other they don't write you a lot
of money it's up here and then I have a
lot of happiness but that doesn't mean
that the to equate to each other as your
happiness risen at the same romano's
your bank account no that's the thing
they don't they don't they don't equate
or do not hide it anyway they're tied to
each other I mean it allows you freedom
and allows you to go places where you
could smile and look at the sunset and
things like that that's what you choose
to do and you enjoy to do right but
there are a lot of people with tons of
money who aren't happy because there is
either they've become a prisoner of
their money or they've become so
consumed with getting money that they
don't allow time for happiness right
life is about balance right you have to
have some type of balance you have like
time for work and it's time for play and
if you don't allow these two things to
co-exist you have an imbalance I've
wanted up now which I could say we were
geniuses and said we're gonna start our
own company you know that's not what
happened you know in the beginning we
went to every single label and every
single label shut the door on us the
genius thing that we did was we didn't
give up
we didn't say because these guys you
know we use that what do they know
approach you know we we didn't give up
at that point
I think that you know I was the genius
thing we did we start selling our own
CDs and we built their own buzz and then
the record company came back to us so
now we had a different negotiation you
know it was in the same artists label
relationship now we retain ownership in
our own company
and it was the best thing for us let's
not get stuck on one thing this lets you
know rap music is about diversity like
if you know you got on those Nikes i'ma
just write you know dunks and it's all
about everyone contribution you know you
had before you had tried Ice Cube Public
Enemy at the same time as did you -
underground was just so many different I
had every album you know was all
different types of sounds and approaches
but it was still great music I'm not
just you know auto-tune is bad you know
their songs that have auto-tune that I
love but when everyone jumps on this
bandwagon and everyone make tries to
make the same exact record I mean I
heard that record from t-pain I liked it
I don't want to hit a hundred times from
a hundred different artists like I went
to a different stuff our job is to find
their genius level talent and then to
apply it in the way that supports that
genius level talent quick example is a
guy named Earl Mann ago who was said to
be way better than Michael Jordan
make the lead yourself juggling I could
have been drunk the circumstance and
gotten away so you have to define you
have defined your genius level talent
but you have to believe on the other
believing it's so hard because people
put this [ __ ] man securities out you
were like when I was younger I went to
my own woman
I had my demo tape my first room I was
really happy about it
I played the phone and I was like
wide-eyed okay it went off the first
thing you say keep up the good work you
say you'll never be better than our Fuji
I know you love me I forget before it
you know but I think that something must
happen to him when he was trying to
pursue his dreams then work out so he
was putting that on me so you have to
even keep with other clothes for you and
love you you have this has so much
belief in this genius really talented
that no matter what anyone says to you
have to have this focus so you have fine
yeah
you can't let nobody put their
insecurities and [ __ ] on you
he just affirmed to me that instincts is
really important in business you know
III didn't go to any proper business
school or any read any super uh follow
any manuals like the record business 101
or anything like that I just pretty much
followed my instincts and he just
reaffirmed that for me that you know
your instincts are very important to you
I love that um you know I love that
thing I'm collaborating you taking the
best of what you do and someone taking
the best of what you're doing you're not
robbing from what they do and then it
problem from what you do and y'all bring
the best of what you are to the table
and you put it in this mix and you see
what happens you know I love that part
of creating so there definitely be a you
know because I I don't believe in those
lines that people put up for music you
know this is for this person this is for
that people you know this is rock this
is blues I just believe good music bad
music and you know put those two
elements in the room and you know see
what happens that that them you know God
the universe the movement whatever it
whatever happens and in that room and I
we not we why whatever happens you know
make great music I started this uh Sean
Carter a scholarship program you know
noticing how education was you know not
being addressed in our neighborhood and
also as a way to show people in our
neighborhood that you know you can be
successful and come back that that
person that used to live in five c mu
534 flushing is not a person in a box
now you know not someone you just see a
concert or see on TV you know most
people that was successful growing up
from wells from never came back so it
was never dialogue or not how'd you do
it what happened there was no mentoring
program there was no going back and
grabbing a person teaching them you know
trade or you know what it is that you're
doing and that person go back and grab
two people and didn't you know and it
goes from it so I figured I'd start with
school because you know education you
know the answer it's the answer thank
you guys so much for watching I made
this video because a bunch of you were
asking for it so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Jersey's top 10 rules most
resonated with you leave it in the
comments I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon